jungen wie der frist dieter schweer und
herzlich willkommen zum letzten video im
jahr 2015 und heute kam max grad eben
mit einer idee zu mir und zwar gesagt
wird mit diesen karten zu tun und zwar
darfst du am anfang jeder gittern runde
eine karte ziehen und dann schaust du
wieviele können wir bitte in dieser
runde einsammeln möchte um nehmen ja
immer die um drei komplexe das heißt
schnell runter das vielleicht noch
millionen mit drei komplett ich werde
versuchen die drei komplette wir zu
schnappen und dann mal flugs auf
finnisch zu spielen
denn wenn die drei komplett eingesammelt
sind dann ist leben vorbei
gott drei das ist das zweitschlechteste
was es ging ja es gibt ja es gibt schon
das ist mein erster block den ich
mitnehmen darf halt in der ganzen auch
er abstürzt nur noch 23
da sind jede menge da hast du die hohe
ehre distanzen zwischen ist ein 2 ich
bin nicht so ein get down routinier
dessert max alter schwede
darunter ok sehr schön da sind einen
letzten zwei da ist einer 92 kunzmann
die komplette holt eigentlich so schade
dass ich so viel mitnehmen darf und mein
letzter kontakt mit 250 und jetzt geht's
die linken blöcke weil vielleicht
resistenz du musst du echt drauf wollen
auf effekte über die knöpfe sind so
viele called me richtig den nehmen
konnte ich denke habe ich ein resistenz
genommen hatte war jetzt bist du bist
bist du am meisten und mir ist sprinter
sprinter sprint die teile und ja ich
nehme ich geb gas ich die preis gibt es
noch so viele komplett an die kommunale
mitnehmen ja
na ja wohl den kopf
ich bin dem hauptgang downs kinos du dir
an das gehört halt wieder runterkommen
ja wohl der kranken hand abgezählt okay
durch die nächste karte von oben direkt
bin ich so ein dass sie durchstarten
kann ok 7 anständig seht ihr das
anständig 77 okay und es geht los
es ist edgar na gut da braucht man glück
dass man überhaupt sieben karten 7
befindet auf die karte der hölle will
den für den fällen die wir nicht hin
kann es am anfang gibt es ja diese break
ach so kost ist zeitlich oder räumlich
begrenzt die welt ich glaube er zeit
nicht echt lustige links und kanada wo
problems missing link links links harald
die absolute seltenheit hier auf etwa
ein comeback zu sehen war
nach vorne könnte schwer werden
aber du darfst nie los 62 hoffentlich
schafft man ja wir können mannschaft
mehr
ok er ging es gibt also wenig gesehen
ich dachte du jetzt den gesehen und
dachte trotz geht schade
ok ja einmal bekannt ist in ordnung es
gehe es geht okay leute was ich aber in
dem heutigen video noch ansprechen
möchte ist ja wie gesagt das letzte
video für 2015 und ich habe in letzter
zeit noch mal öfters darüber nachgedacht
wie viel spaß eigentlich macht
runterzufallen in gap down
nee ich habe darüber nachgedacht wie die
wenig youtuber den einzelnen zuschauer
würdigen
darüber habe ich nachgedacht das heißt
die die youtuber denken über ihre
zuschauer nur noch in zahlen nach also
man ich kenne das ja ich weiss es unter
youtube ist zum beispiel so ja der der
sohn so viele abonnenten
der hat so viele klicks und anderes
besser weil er mehr klicks hat oder mehr
abonnenten hat hier oder eine 880 81
sehr gut deswegen möchte ich einfach die
gelingt es selbst auch manchmal mache
sich der qualm quantifizieren nennt man
das also quasi nur noch in zahlen
erfassen und es ist total
menschenunwürdig eigentlich farc
nein das ist menschenunwürdig wollte ich
sagen weil man da die wertschätzung für
das individuum total verliert also die
wertschätzung dafür dass da draußen
einfach ein mensch sitzt und gerne den
mist den man auf youtube hochladen sich
anschaut das ist was faszinierend das
ist ja nicht wunderschön und da darüber
denkt man glaube ich ganz ganz wenig
nach so als creator deswegen ist das so
ein thema was mich beschäftigt und da
will ich aber sagen ich mir in letzter
zeit bewusst geworden sagen den letzten
tagen bewusst geworden dass einfach
20.000 individuen da draußen in
deutschland österreich in der schweiz
jeden tag meine videos anschauen und das
einfach der hammer alles um 20.000
menschen jetzt kommen die luxemburger
sollten die luxemburger auch 20.000
menschen die einfach alle genauso viel
wert sind wie ich so einfach da draußen
und haben mir spaß haben meine videos
anzuschauen und deswegen wollte ich
jetzt das klingt ein bisschen
abgedroschen aber es kommt bald kommt
für mich von herzen es wegen wollte ich
jetzt einfach jedem einzelnen menschen
also jedem einzelnen da draußen
wohlgemerkt nicht nur 20.000 klicks
whatever soll jedem individuum dass
meine videos schaut mal danke sagen für
die unterstützung in 2015 einen dicken
schmatzer auf den dann kaufen gea westen
viel einstecken können von allen reisen
schwert von iron wie wettstein schwert
enchanted und ganz entscheidend auch
schaffen das alles schon mit mir damit
herrscht ein schwert
levelone enchantment 222 extra herzen
und gold damit ziemlich gut eingekauft
wird nicht oder
entscheidend aber noch zehn sekunden
hatte gott nein das ist ja wohl das hat
gerade noch geklappt bestimmen jetzt
nochmal rein also war es ein bisschen
abgesägte soll jetzt auch nicht zu zu
sentimental ich schlimmeres klingen oder
so aber ja es ist es war wichtig darüber
nachzudenken dass einfach jeder einzelne
klick da draußen von den menschen
gemacht wird der auch selbst gefühl hat
und genauso
denkt wurde war also das einfach dass
menschen sind da draußen nicht klicks
oder abonnenten jungen wie der frist
ich wollte schon sagen du musst die
runde sowieso nehmen weil es einfach
mega cool junge schärfe 43 habe ich mich
ins wasser bewusst alles gut also und
jetzt klar verbringen würden größer denn
da jetzt wie blieb scheffel 4 eltern
viel zu kleiner basar wo du hast ja
feier aspect aber ist hier bei spectro
flog er wird mit dem chef chef 4 ist
also da kann wahrscheinlich die
wenigsten mithalten
das ist schon mega also denn equipment
nachteil mit ein bisschen glück direkt
am anfang ausgeglichen
ja kann man las man auf jeden fall jetzt
jetzt wir nicht in die mitte geraten
zwischen den beiden
wir wollen jetzt das scheiße
er hat mich war schön geben jetzt ist es
der fed auch eine feier ist weg aber die
wollen mich jetzt hat die abgewechselt
das ist kacke
das ist sehr kacke auch gibt auch ein
denkmal meinte der gut wenn die jako was
machen wir jetzt unter anderem außen rum
das waren es nicht mal wie ärgerlich das
war voll die gute runde es hat
eigentlich so halblinks gepasst sollte
ich für ein foul gelb
das ist eigentlich bin get down load
aber gesehen und 2016 wieder quasi
morgen bis dann haut rein macht's gut